the morning after his devastating ball  from a 40-foot cliff  Ott's League with his wife Jane by his  side fights through trauma in intensive  care  hot  he sort of told me what happened but I  don't get it  remember falling  I'm very good move my leg mom remember  knowing I was in trouble like those  mountains my whole life hope something  like this never happens you can't see a  club no just stepped into an abyss  ankle couple screws in there broke my  hip girl a shoulder blade and then  pretty much fractured broke all of my  ribs kind of dampens my moving out to  the hunters Gavin plans a little bit  know how badly he's hurt  just like it's really hard if you're a  mom or or married to somebody like you  care more about the other people like I  wish it was me on him so it's really  devastating and it's hard that it's hard  to know somebody's hurt in my tires  sister this definitely changes  everything  Alaska the last frontier all new Sunday  at 9:00 part of mega week on Discovery